[Music]
Georgia's ruling party has said it's
going to drop the controversial Bill to
regulate what it calls foreign agents
thousands of people have protested in
the capital Tbilisi for two days against
a law they say could silence critics of
the government
[Applause]
standoffs with police outside the
Parliament building have continued
through early morning the bill would
have required all organizations which
get at least 20 percent of their funding
from abroad to be branded as foreign
agents
when joining us live from tibilisi is
hakaba kemoliche who's the political
Secretary of the opposition party for
Georgia and the former head of Georgia's
National Security Council Office so very
good to have you with us on Al Jazeera
what has really motivated the the
lawmakers to pull this back is it about
the protests or is it also pressure from
the EU
I think first of all it's the result of
the high pressure from the Georgian
Society because 85 percent of the
Georgian Society is very European and
the European perspective is written
within the Georgian Constitution and
this draft law introduced by the ruling
party was directly undermining the
Georgian Constitution and I think the
withdrawal of this draft law by the
ruling party is a particular result of
the society's extreme anger what we have
been facing within the last 48 hours
talk for those of us who are just coming
to this story uh fairly fresh talk us
through what the objections were to this
because if I understand it correctly the
US has similar regulations and they say
it's not to suppress open debate it is
simply to specify the country or the
foreign entity between behind
organizations making comments supporters
of that would say that that is simply
adding more context what's the issue
with this spell
thank you very much for for very
interesting question
um yes uh the let's say like the
introducers of this rough law have been
using this particular argument that what
might work in the United States why it
would not work in Georgia the answer is
very simple this draft this law was
introduced in the United States in 1968
and um in the United States the
institutions are very strong and there
is very good sense of understanding of
the legislation within the within the
United States and in Georgia it's a
different let's say environment we don't
have strong institutions unfortunately
this is the country with transition
economy transition uh democracy at the
same time we're building the
institutions right now and what might be
working in a western countries it might
not work in the uh context of Georgia
this is arguments a the and the argument
B is exactly the one which which was
pretty much let's say very well spread
within the Georgian Society because what
would introduced by the same argument by
the way in 1920 12 in Moscow in Russia
that was done pretty much in the same
manner in felici just two three days ago
what uh the aim and the goal of this law
was pretty much similar what the
Russians used to have back 10 years ago
to suppress the um NGO sector to
suppress TV stations to suppress the
Independent Media and generally to
somehow choke the independent let's say
criticism which might be a vital for the
sake of democracy in Georgia right now
do you think that there is a chance that
this is the last of this bill or is it
more likely that supporters are so
determined that this bill is the right
thing to do that we they are going to
reshapen and at some point in the future
we're going to see attempts to
reintroduce it
people are already making after hearing
that the ruling party actually stepped
back because uh there have been several
president or presidents within uh
be our history of the of Georgian dreams
ruling when they said one thing and they
totally under one when they promised one
thing and at some point change changed
this uh promise in a swift manner after
several months when they protest somehow
are decreased and I think some it might
be it might be tricky to look uh and to
directly let's say
um believe in what ruling party is
saying or doing right now but at the end
of the day we still rely on the Georgian
societies absolute majorities let's say
uh pressure internal pressure on the
Georgian government which actually
effectively works right now so far very
good to have you with us
thank you very much indeed for your time
pleasure is mine thank you very much